Netflix has been ramping up its
programming slate in a big way in recent
years for better and for worse there
have been hit series that make it a must
subscribe like orange is the new black
and stranger things but there have also
been a lot of projects that were
severely overhyped no entertainment
giant is perfect and with that in mind
here's a look at some Netflix originals
that didn't live up to the hype Marco
Polo Marco Polo was hyped by Netflix as
quote a timeless tale of power adventure
betrayal and lust that combines deft
storytelling and cinematic ambition
despite all that lofty language however
the series was a bonafide flop sure the
show did earn some points for boasting a
culturally appropriate cast and the
company's CEO allotted its popularity
and called it a massive success though
the 24 percent Rotten Tomatoes score for
the show's four seasons suggests critics
thought otherwise after two seasons
Netflix couldn't continue funding the
series and cancelled it with a reported
200 million dollar loss to show for all
their efforts why do we need more I will
tell you because that is what comes next
since 8:00 when the Wachowski set out to
make their first small screen series
their names alone were enough to draw
some enthusiastic interest in the sci-fi
show it certainly didn't hurt that sense
8 was met with mostly positive reviews
and was recognized by the GLAAD Media
Awards for its inclusion of LGBTQ
characters after two seasons however
Netflix decided to pull the plug on the
series the show simply didn't attract
enough of a following to justify its
cost of about 9 million dollars in
episode following a roaring audience
reaction to the show's cancellation
Netflix did decide to bring it back for
a single two-hour finale episode to
offer closure the get-down
the 70 set musical drama cost a whopping
120 million dollars to make making it
Netflix as pricey a series up to that
point the streaming service also pulled
out all the stops to promote the
get-down including using graffiti art in
big cities the investment appeared sound
and favorable reviews certainly seemed
to echo that however the show's
viewership didn't quite measure up to
expectations with just over 3 million
pairs of eyes tuning in during the first
month of its run the show's failure to
match the ratings of far less expensive
original series meant it was predictably
canned after a single two-part season
[Music]
keep loving me and I promise it's gonna
all be alright
Marvel's Iron Fist Netflix had been on a
roll with its Marvel adaptations but
Iron Fist was met with stunning disfavor
despite being heavily binge de pon
release after a bevy of pre-release hype
comparing the series to its well-liked
predecessors
some critics declared the inaugural
season a directionless snooze fest while
others took umbrage with the appeal of
the title hero himself it didn't help
that the show was also beset with
allegations of cultural appropriation
Iron Fist critical whomping didn't spark
a downward trend for the streaming
services Marvel shows to come but season
1 showrunner Scott Buck was still
replaced for the eventual second season
Danny Rand disjointed it isn't just
Pottery to say the Netflix had high
hopes for disjointed the pod centric
series featured Kathy Bates as a
cannabis shop owner and was spearheaded
by TV sitcom giant Chuck Lorre in other
words it was a stoner show with solid
talent in front of and behind the
cameras what could possibly go wrong
well despite some stylish marketing
efforts that included branded marijuana
strains being doled out at a pop-up
dispensary the series simply failed to
resonate with its intended audience
critics found it to be plagued by
obvious jokes in a scattered plot that
unfortunately made good on the series
name and the show ended up being the
worst reviewed series of the summer
after a two-part season the show was
unceremoniously snuffed out by Netflix I
am cool you know why because I don't
take pot pot is lame bright this late
2017 sci-fi fantasy movie was the focus
of a massive bidding war that resulted
in Netflix forking over 90 million
dollars for the rights bright featured
Will Smith and joel edgerton as
cross-species buddy cop leads
specifically a human and an orc both
serving as an extended metaphor for
real-life racial tensions despite an
aggressive front page promotional push
by Netflix the reviews for the film
we're an absolute bloodbath even so
Netflix wasn't deterred by the bad buzz
and decided to greenlight a sequel and
now you keep doing ru gangster stuff I'm
just trying to sell my house the
Cloverfield paradox with the third
installment in JJ Abrams loosely
connected series of Cloverfield films it
was the method of delivery that felt
like a big power play Netflix dropped
the film's trailer during the
eighteen Super Bowl and revealed that
itted be available for streaming just
after the game was over thanks to the
unexpected success of the first sequel
10 Cloverfield Lane and the depth of
talent in paradoxes cast the film was
watched by 5 million people during its
first week online
despite that savvy marketing though the
film was absolutely eviscerated by
critics who are even more disappointed
in the film after its major marketing
splash
mute Duncan Jones waited a long time to
make mute the so called spiritual sequel
to his stunning 2009 sci-fi film moon
when Netflix finally helped usher the 16
years in the making movie into reality
Jones fans were definitely paying
attention perhaps Jones should have let
the film percolate a few more years
however because the final product was
lackluster to put it kindly after all
that build-up what resulted was an
ultimately lifeless disorganized and
derivative film that didn't come
anywhere near living up to the
expectations set by its creator it's
hard to be this good-looking
responsibility sorry oh that's it
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
please check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]